양자 정보와 계산 이해하기에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Watrous이고, IBM
Quantum의 교육 기술 디렉터예요. 이번이 시리즈의 10번째 강의이고, 세 번째 단원의 두 번째 강의인데요,
양자 정보의 일반적인 공식화에 관한 단원이에요. 이번 강의는 채널에 대한 내용인데,
채널은 양자 정보를 저장하는 시스템의 변화를 나타내요. 여기에는 다음과 같은 유용한 연산들이 포함되는데요,
unitary gate와 양자 circuit에 의해 수행되는 연산들, 그리고 노이즈처럼 우리가 피하고 싶은 변화들도 포함돼요. 측정도 설명할 수 있는데요,
채널로서의 측정은 다음 강의에서 다룰 거예요. 채널이라는 용어는
정보 이론에서 왔는데요, 정보 이론은 무엇보다도 잡음이 있는 통신
채널의 정보 전달 용량을 연구해요. 그래서 채널을 생각할 때, 우리는 통신
채널에 대해 추상적으로 생각하고 있는 거예요. 복잡한 계산을 통신 채널로 생각하는 게 좀 이상하게 느껴질 수도 있지만,
어떤 방식으로든 정보를 변환하는 과정이라는 일반적인 개념을 가리키는 단어가 필요해요. 좋든 싫든
채널이라는 단어가 굳어졌는데, 이는 정보 이론이, 특히
1940년대 Claude Shannon의 연구가 양자 정보와 계산에 미친 엄청난 영향 때문일 거예요. 이번 강의의
개요를 소개할게요. 기초부터 시작해서 채널이 무엇인지 정의하고, 단순화된 공식화에서의 unitary 연산이
어떻게 채널로 표현될 수 있는지도 다룰 거예요. 또한 채널의 볼록 결합이 채널이 된다는 것도 이야기할 텐데요,
왜 이 볼록성 개념이 계속 나오는지 궁금하시다면, 그건 이게 양자 정보 이론에서 정말로 근본적으로 중요한 수학적 개념이기 때문이에요.
또한 채널의 예시들도 살펴볼 텐데, 특히 qubit 채널을 볼 거예요. 이건 강의 나머지 부분에서도
계속 다시 나올 거예요. 강의의 두 번째 부분에서는 채널을 수학적으로 표현하는 세 가지 방법을 이야기할 거예요.
구체적으로 Stinespring 표현, Kraus 표현, 그리고 Choi
표현을 다룰 거예요. 이 이름들은 이 표현들의 발전에 중요한 기여를 한 세 사람의 이름을 딴 거예요. 세 번째이자
마지막 부분에서는 이 세 가지 표현이 실제로 동등하다는 것을 수학적으로 증명할 거예요. 또한 이것들이
채널의 정의를 모두 올바르게 특성화한다는 것도 다룰 거예요. 제 생각에는 정말 멋진 수학적 증명이고, 이 다양한
표현들이 어떻게 서로 관련되고 어떻게 작동하는지 명확하게 이해하는 데 도움이 될 거예요. 기초부터 시작해서
채널이란 무엇인가라는 질문을 다뤄 볼게요. 강의 시작 부분에서 말씀드렸듯이, 채널은 변화를 설명해요.
구체적으로는 양자 정보를 저장하는 시스템에서 이산 시간 변화를 나타내요. 여기서 이산 시간
변화라는 건 연속적인 과정과는 반대로, 두 개의 구별되는 시간 사이에 발생하는 변화를 생각하는 거예요.
예를 들어 무한소의 아주 작은 시간 간격에 걸쳐 생각하는 연속적인 과정과는 달라요. 채널에는
양자 gate와 circuit에 의해 수행되는 unitary 연산 같은 유용한 연산들, 그리고 노이즈로 인한 변화가 포함돼요.
하지만 이번 강의에서는 주로 채널을 추상적인 수학적 용어로 생각할 거예요. 유용한 것과 그렇지 않은 것을
굳이 구분할 필요는 없어요. 채널의 일반적인 이름으로는 그리스 대문자 파이,
사이, 델타 같은 것들을 써요. 특정 채널을 가리킬 때는 다른 문자를 쓸 거예요. 단순한 상황에서
어떤 밀도 행렬 ρ로 표현되는 상태에 있는 시스템이 있고, 그 시스템에 채널 Φ를 적용하면,
결과는 밀도 행렬 Φ(ρ)로 표현되는 상태의 시스템이에요. 즉, 주어진
채널 Φ를 특정 크기의 밀도 행렬에 적용할 수 있는 함수로 생각하는 거예요. 다시 말해서
이 채널을 적용하는 특정 시스템의 밀도 행렬에 적용하는 거예요. 채널이 유효한 채널로 간주되려면 몇 가지 요건을 충족해야 해요.
첫째, 채널은 선형 사상이에요. 이건 우리가 갖고 있는 상황과 완전히 유사한데요,
양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서 양자 상태 벡터에 대한 연산이 반드시 선형이어야 하는 것처럼요.
그리고 확률적 연산이 선형인 고전 정보의 표준 공식화에서도 마찬가지예요. 정말로 원한다면 이 선형성이라는
기본 요건에 의문을 제기할 수도 있어요. 하지만 확률 이론 모두와 일관된 이론을 원한다면,
그리고 양자 상태를 밀도 행렬로 표현하기로 선택했다면, 우리에게 선택의 여지가 없고 채널이 선형이라는 것을 그냥 받아들여야 해요.
두 번째 요건은 채널이 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환해야 한다는 거예요. 이건 완전히 타당한데요,
시스템의 상태를 밀도 행렬로 표현하기로 선택하고, 어떤 상태에 있는 시스템에 채널을 적용하면, 결과도 유효한 상태여야 하고 따라서
밀도 행렬로 표현돼야 해요. 하지만 여기서 매우 중요한 점을 추가해야 해요. 이 요건은
채널을 밀도 행렬로 상태가 표현되는 고립된 시스템에 적용할 때만 적용되는 게 아니에요.
복합 시스템이 있고 그 상태가 어떤 밀도 행렬로 표현될 때, 그 시스템의 일부에만
채널을 적용하는 경우에도 적용돼요. 이것이 채널에 두는 요건들이고, 이것들이
양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화와 고전 정보의 표준 공식화 모두에서 연산에 대한 요건들과 매우 유사하다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서 연산은 unitary 행렬로 표현되는데, 이건 그것들이
주어진 시스템에 대해 항상 양자 상태 벡터를 양자 상태 벡터로 변환하는 선형 사상에 정확히 대응하기 때문이에요.
마찬가지로 확률적 연산은 확률 행렬로 표현되는데, 이것들이
항상 확률 벡터를 확률 벡터로 변환하는 것들이기 때문이에요. 여기서는 밀도 행렬을 다루고 있고,
복합 시스템에 관한 추가 요건이 있어요. 이건 양자 상태 벡터에는 필요하지 않은 것으로 밝혀졌는데,
확률 벡터도 마찬가지예요. 그 외에는 요건들이 유사하고, 어떤 의미에서는 양자 상태를 밀도 행렬로
표현하는 선택에 의해 강요된 것들이에요. 채널에 대한 추가 세부사항들이 있는데, 강의 전반에 걸쳐
채널의 입력 및 출력 시스템을 어떻게 생각할지에 대한 관례와, 채널이 항상 밀도 행렬을
밀도 행렬로 변환해야 한다는 요건에 대한 더 자세한 내용도 있어요. 우선 모든 채널에는
입력 시스템과 출력 시스템이 있다고 가정해요. 원하는 대로 이름을 붙일 수 있지만,
이번 강의에서는 입력 시스템을 X, 출력 시스템을 Y라고 부를 거예요. 개념적으로 채널은
입력 시스템을 출력 시스템으로 변환해요. 그래서 입력과 출력 시스템은 동시에 공존하지 않아요.
X에서 시작해서 채널이 적용 또는 수행되고, 그 결과는 X가 Y로 변환된 것이에요. Y의 상태는
채널과 관련된 선형 사상에 의해 결정돼요. 채널의 입력과 출력 시스템이 같을 필요는 없고, 특히
같은 수의 고전적 상태를 가질 필요도 없어요. 하지만 입력과 출력 시스템이 실제로 같은 시스템이거나 다른 방식으로